whoever he told us to do is is
without any doubt that's why one of the
Miracles Islam goes in line with our
human nature from our human nature which
is our sound reasoning our natural
explanation that you want to have a good
slight healthy life and to live that
good life in a healthy life you have to
also to create first because if the
foundation is weak and corrupted the
branches will be weak or corrupted when
your foundation is solid and strong you
will have a solid brushes and there is
nothing that will make you stronger in
this life except by connecting yourself
to your creator by following his
teachings that's why you know even
though it was this year
in the Western World in the media even
the Eastern world yeah like okay in
Australia every single day in Australia
Germany France there is articles
speaking in a bad way about Islam yeah
or Muslims but yet the first proven
religion in the western world is Islam
why because Islamic goes in line with
our human nature so the human beings
those who have sound reasoning they will
gravitate towards Islam and the example
I give is that imagine I make a padlock
and I'll give you a key I said if you
want to open that fat look or this bad
look you need this kid so Allah pray as
with the padlock so generally we know I
should be good to my Creator I should be
grateful to him I should worship him the
way he wants I should be good to my
parents however you know the detailed
information and you need to open up that
look
is Islamic Revelation or legislation you
understand that's why you know what is
the Shahid that says
what does it mean about witness that I
should appreciate and worship my Creator
who is Allah
according to the teacher Muhammad
because
as a Muslim I believe I was alive at the
time of Jesus to worship God correctly
I have to follow Jesus teaching before
Jesus Moses however those Prophet
Messengers because the teaching was not
for all the time not for everyone also
so it was corrupted
the Romans Cup today yes paganism you
know you can see that clearly so no
doubt about that yesterday I was in
Bristol University I got decomposition
at least I'm really opened my eyes
you know because like I said many people
say there's too many that rule is
established
okay there is rules but those rulings
are the good food
that's the question ask myself if it's
good for me that's what I want to do I
mean there's nothing that even if you go
to work you have to follow rules you
understand if you want to go gym you
want to get bigger stronger there is a
way to do it so everything in our life
he has a message
foreign
[Music]
the house the chicken and I noticed I go
to the gym my strength will be like 60
like double like how it was my time
they've been like far 60 weeks
of 5 kg and muscle just muscle alone
the question you ask yourself how a man
that exists 1 000 400 years ago Muhammad
who couldn't read and write his communal
is a perfect way of life
except by going back to your creator the
true creators that's right what's your
name sorry Thomas nice to meet you my
name is that's why Thomas
Islam came to Chris have five kids one
of the Islam company what does that mean
it means that Islam Worship in the true
God is very important because if you
don't want to be true God you start
following our desires and the outcome of
following our desires what happened it's
like interrupted instead of just doing
guesswork harming your body or harming
your intellect or how many neighbors who
are having the most important thing I'm
in the right of Allah because what is
oppression oppression when you put
something in a place that doesn't
deserve it or you give something to
someone doesn't deserve it so if you
give I like it as an example I give
imagine Allah forbid Thomas yeah you go
to your house tonight
and there's a fire everywhere in your
house
or you wake up at night and there's a
fire everywhere may Allah forbid yeah
and you try your best to Serve Yourself
and you couldn't you gave up I came and
I saved your life what would you say to
me
could you thank me
yes of course it saved your life that
burns and I saved your life you're gonna
remember me and you're going to thank me
likewise you should remember and thank
the one who gave us alive for free
foreign
that's why in Islam we have the concept
of forgiveness
when we pray after the prayer what we
say Allah
forgive us in Allah why we say that
because we know regardless how much you
wish Allah we will never be able to
reply back Allah for His blessings so we
humble ourselves so Islam is good for us
no doubt about that you know make sense
is not just for you Islam for everything
that's what it is
there's three types of Islam there is
universal Islam what does mean universe
is the mean everything from me to Allah
no one can make a day
if Allah wants to take you soon no one
can stop it so everyone is a Muslim from
the prospective means everyone has to
submit to Allah which is universal law
no one can escape it yes if Allah wants
to cause like earthquake no one can stop
it second one there is a general Islam
General islami all the prophets and
messages came with Islam and their
specific Islam which is the Islam that
Prophet Muhammad came with you
understand so when we pray look Islam is
that you have to wash Allah by way of
physical way spiritual wealth spiritual
way intellectual way Financial way it
kind of uh
economic way social way is why Allah is
the king of everything and he taught us
how to live our life that's why what is
Islam Islam is a way of life
ever even even I shake your hand with a
right hand
you know if I want to eat with my rates
yeah the right you know if our example
but before I go inside my house there is
a prayer that I do before I leave
there's a prayer I do if I meet my
brother there's something I say assalamu
alaikum you know before I'm leaving
if you go through hardship make Dua our
life everything is just connect Allah
you know that's why you know the the
suicide suicide there is very low
amongst the Muslims very low Encompass
other religions and even though some
Muslim countries are very poor you know
from the financial way but they're very
happy why because we know whatever
happens by Allah
you know what we have to understand
Thomas as well you know this stuff is a
test
and sooner or later we'll continue this
life how many people won't sleep they
never wake up how many people left the
house they never come back
I've got a friend of mine I remember
he called me and his wife Hannah won't
sleep she never wake up
he never expected that that's what our
Prophet told us visit the graveyard so
why why did Prophet Muhammad told us the
graveyard because when you go to the
graveyard those who are inside the
graves they won't like us here and today
they are buried but it's too late for
them that's Allah in the Quran prepare
yourself for the day of judgment Allah
Allah will ask about your actions good
or bad and the most important good the
is to testify there's no one worthy
worship Allah
then a prayer then a charity then of
course step by step you know I always
give the example imagine you have a big
cake out of you
and if you eat the the big cake all of
it at once what happened you vomit so in
order for you to feel the sweetness of
the cake you take it by Bit by Bit
likewise Islam step by step you know
when I told you if I saved your life in
the fire you would thank me straight
away
so thank you something and probably
won't give your life imagine you have a
deadly disease in your kidney may Allah
forbid and I came and I removed that
disease from the kidney you'll be very
grateful to me
you know while we speak it we are
benefiting from the the blessings of
Allah oxygen when you go to hospitals
they charge us
but we're getting it for free from Allah
that's why from the day of judgments
Allah will ask the disbeliever he said
if
I give you too many Universe for example
would you sacrifice those Universe for
the sake of saving yourself from the
punishment today
said oh my Lord yes I will do without
hesitation Allah will say to him I ask
you one thing worship me alone and
understand
ing so it's too late now that's what
Allah is the most merciful Allah will
never punish anyone and seeks are for
the truth to them this is not that we
are attempting
with is nothing in comparison to
Paradise
the stand Thomas so you know you should
become Muslim
to say which is a bad witness there's
nothing worthy of worship except Allah
the messenger of Allah you can say in
Arabic
that's the first thing to become Muslim
then you start learning step by step and
you have good to see here you see so if
you say it now okay
alhamdulillah shall I tell you in Arabic
okay so say after me Allah
Allah
except Allah
is the last messenger
and the servant Allah
congratulations
so much
Islam has changed my life Allah's Mercy
is greater than any greater than my
mother my father my sister my brother
believe me this is the start of a
journey that you're going to appreciate
you're gonna be filled with gratitude